Ukraine has dismissed Russian claims
that it killed hundreds of soldiers in a
missile attack on a chromatosk schools
and apartment blocks were damaged in the
attack in the eastern city but Ukraine's
military says no one was killed Russia
said the strike was in retaliation for
Ukraine's New Year attack which killed
dozens of Russian soldiers
the rising explosion and then another a
series of explosion and one made the
windows Shake really there's nothing
else to tell you just a normal day
I just went back to sleep I thought
about what to do next but I just went
back to bed
let's go to Charles Stratford who isn't
key for us and Charles is there any
evidence at this stage to back up
Russia's claim it killed hundreds of
Ukrainian soldiers
absolutely no evidence at all as yet in
a flat dismissal by Ukrainian
authorities that such an attack happened
we know that crematolsk is often
targeted it's often described as a
Garrison Town it has had lots of
military in it for four years
um it's as I say traditionally a town
associated with the military and of
course you can imagine that those
numbers of Ukrainian troops have
increased
um as we've gone into this war but no
evidence whatsoever I think this is
important to put it in the context as
you alluded to in the intro of this
attack by the Ukrainian forces on the
town of machiaveka on the in the early
hours of New Year's Day
when they initially claim that hundreds
of Russian conscripts had been killed in
that attack and we saw for the first
time an admission by the Russians that
they said 89 conscripts had been killed
at a conscript Center a vocational
school that was being used as some sort
of conscript Center there in the wake of
that admission there was a lot of anger
on social media amongst Ukrainian sorry
Russian army bloggers um a lot of anger
amongst the Russian public as well
because the Russians blamed that attack
or the high casualties on what they said
was that the use of mobile phones by
Russian conscripts that was given
basically a signal to Ukrainian forces
that allowed them to to to attack that
Center so it's understood that uh this
uh this announcement yesterday that 600
Ukrainian troops were killed in this
attack of on chroma tools because very
much kind of an attempt by the Russians
to basically set the record straight and
look good in the face of as I say such
big criticism for such a high death toll
in the meantime there has been some
interesting announcements with respect
to developments along the Eastern Front
a lot of fighting again around the town
of bakmut but specifically the town of
solidar now that's a few kilometers
north of Bahamut it is a salt mining
town it has been heavily contested in
recent months and we've heard claims and
counter claims in recent Days by both
sides of of advances there and we are
hearing now certainly according to
president zielinski the Ukrainian
president saying that the ukrainians are
having to deploy additional fighting
units to bakmut it's understood in order
to try and repel what seemed to be
increasing attacks by the Russians in
that area
um they've also been reports with
respect to the area north of bakmut
along the Donetsk
lugansk border the Ukrainian head of the
regional military administration of
Lucan Sergey gayday
saying that the situation was very
complicated he said that there were
movements by the ukrainians in some
areas in other areas there was progress
being made by the Russian forces and he
says that he expects the situation to
get increasingly difficult as these
winter temperatures continue to drop
it's expected to be down to around minus
17 in the next few days in the east of
the country it's around -5 here today in
Kiev with a with a bitter wind so of
course when those temperatures drop the
ground gets harder and gaide the lugansk
authority there the Ukrainian
Authority saying that they are seeing
the movement of heavy weaponry and and
more Russian units into the area around
the town of cremina which we know the
ukrainians have been pushing slowly very
gradually towards in recent weeks okay
Charles Stratford thank you so much for
that update from Keith